you might notice as well these are these
groups we call them classes I referred
to that before so instead of just figure
out the individuals I'm thinking about
them collectively okay I don't have to
necessarily class them this way I could
cost them in verge of five or I can
cross them in I think the same Pearson
2002 1922 39 etc and you can see it's
even more pronounced in this cluster in
the middle does that make sense yeah
okay so I want us to water in Africa and
we're going to UM construct one of these
you're going to need to draw some data
with you okay so I asked you to get your
ruler out now what I'd like you to do is
just have them just draw this you don't
need to draw the data we'll write the
data rather you don't have to worry
about the numbers but if you could
construct this for me I'll zoom in a
little bit so you can see clear up clear
up and then I'll zoom back out there so
you can see this is not just a frequency
distribution table this is pretty
frequency so it looks to me like we've
got two four six a 10 or nine and a half
Rose if you want up into three columns
what makes is grouped is the over here
you've got not individual scores but
categories classes groups have data
groups of scores then I'm going to put
in two okay now as you construct that
I'm gonna start to fill it out so you
can see how this is gonna work you can
um for only once you have a complete
table let me zoom back out so now you
can see the Donna
so the question is how do we turn this
into a grouped frequency distribution
table right well the easiest way and the
you've got to make sure you don't miss
anything here is just to look at the
data and enter it one by one this is why
there's a tally column into your table
so I'm gonna do it in a nice systematic
way and I'm gonna cross things out as I
go because honestly the most common
problem I have when I'm doing these is I
forget if I've entered one it or not I'm
like wait am i up to the third one or
the fourth one and then you just enter
it again and you're confused
so here's the way I'm gonna do it I'm
going to go over to my table on the
right I'm going to put a mark where I
see a number and then I'll cross it off
okay you can do it in reverse order if
you like cross it off and then put it in
the table whatever it suits you is fine
so the first number is 244 which group
at which class is that in the second
last right so I'm gonna put my tally and
then I'm gonna cross off okay I'm gonna
keep going to 20 cross off to 32 cross
off 195 cross off you get the idea okay
so you see by going through this process
nice and methodically I'm going to get
not just the individual bits because you
can see look how many different kinds of
scores we've got here you're gonna get
like one of this two of that one of our
nobody patterns I'm gonna get my tallies
right now because it's gonna take us
some time and I don't want to bore you
with the whole process of me going
through you can complete yourself let me
show you one that I've finished earlier
okay so I've gone through and I've
counted my ties that you can get to this
point having um Canada all up so all I
need to do now is finish it off by
actually doing the count for the tallies
to do some copying like what would
subpoenaed okay how many of I got in the
category the class 182 or 189 to looks
like I've got 5 plus 3 which is 8
what's this 11 another 8 the team 10
okay wonderful okay so you can see here
actually this is one of the questions in
the exercise that you've got question
three if I wanted to or near to or were
asked to I could add on to the
right-hand side I could add on a
cumulative frequency column I showed you
how to do that yesterday by adding up
the differences like so and you could
get that if I wanted to I could put
relative frequency over here by saying
well this is two out of whatever the
total is this is ten out of the total
twenty one out of the total and so on so
this is the way I've constructed this
okay grouping data often helps us see
patterns and so it's a great skill to be
able to understand one last thing this
table they've given you the classes
right frequently they'll say okay well
here are some of our clusters you could
use can you group it in a different way
with the data look different if you do
the different way well how about can you
tell me what classes would be
appropriate with this data so you can
cover those kinds of things in the
questions have a go